welcome everyone thank you for joining
us today
as we begin the thermo fisher scientific
asia-pacific japan genetic solutions
tour 2020
my name is banti sangvi and i will be
your moderator for this session
we will be kicking off this event by
talking about various genetic analysis
solutions
the size core v2 research as well as the
emerging applications in this area of
research
first we will hear from dr anjali shah
who is our senior director
global product management clinical
sequencing division at thermo fisher
scientific
anjali leads a dedicated team of product
managers who were recently involved in
developing the ampliseq sars
core v2 ngs panel on our iron torrent
sequencing platforms
for a complete biography on dr shah
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today she will talk to us about some of
these efforts as well as the overall
genetics analysis solution for
sas cov2 research focusing on
applications
in discovery and epidemiological
surveillance research
we encourage you to submit your
questions in the q a box
and dr shah will address them at the end
of her presentation
please join me in welcoming dr angelicia
thank you for the great introduction and
welcome everyone to the genetic
solutions tour
2020 it's a great honor and privilege
for me
to be the first speaker to present to
you
our genetic analysis solutions for sars
kobe 2 research
for those of you who haven't seen the
latest statistics on the coronavirus
pandemic
there are over 8 million confirmed cases
around the world
with 435 000 deaths in 188 countries
at thermo fisher scientific we have a
history to respond to public health
crises
in so many different respects whether it
be providing
personal protective equipment detecting
deadly pathogens using our qpcr
technologies
or employing next generation sequencing
not only to gain epidemiological
insights
but also to provide tools for
understanding
host response and advancing vaccine
development and efficacy
you may have already heard about our
previous efforts
with infectious disease agents including
ebola
h1n1 and zika
our strengths are really fueled by our
industry-leading scale
and unmatched depth of capabilities
you may recognize many of our leading
brands shown above
including applied biosystems in vitrogen
and paytheon
because of the innovation application
breadth and expertise
and unmatched service and support that
thermo fisher scientific provides
we can be your trusted partner for viral
discovery
pathogen detection and epidemiological
surveillance
to name a few applications to really
help you
gain biological insights about this
novel virus
and help reduce the spread of this
disease
so let me start by introducing you to
our broad portfolio
of genetic analysis platforms to advance
your infectious disease research
as shown here we offer a broad portfolio
of genetic analysis technologies to
support
your sars cov2 research
today i'll be focusing primarily on next
generation sequencing
and capillary electrophoresis which
powers our sanger sequencing and
fragment analysis
applications
with our ion torrent next generation
sequencing portfolio
we really enable end-to-end workflows
for viral research
as shown here our technology really
provides the ability to access
the numerous applications
across the infectious disease spectrum
whether it be viral discovery and typing
to vaccine research and discovery
we have made significant investments
over the years
in accelerating our turnaround time to
results
and automating our next generation
sequencing workflows
for easier adoption lower intervention
and improved lab efficiency
there's two important points that i want
you to remember about the ion torrent
technology
it's that we have a superior accuracy of
variance
we have the lowest substitution error
rate for
single nucleotide variants in the
industry
why is this important because as viruses
mutate and involve
it's critical to accurately identify
these changes to inform disease severity
and host response secondly with our
targeted resequencing approach
we enable higher success rates we're
able to access and
analyze a wide variety of samples
including swabs saliva
blood sputum and stool
we can do this without the need for
culture and with the highest sensitivity
approaching viral loads as low as
20 copies
as shown here our applied biosystems
genetic analyzers
are a trusted standard for sanger
sequencing and fragment analysis
you probably recognize these instruments
as they have been used most commonly for
the identification and discovery
of novel pathogens
our next generation sequencing and
capillary electrophoresis technologies
really serve the spectrum of
applications across
infectious disease research everything
from
viral discovery and detection all the
way
to host genetics and population studies
with all of these
applications being backed by
unmatched service and support
so now let me show you how our genetic
analysis technologies can be used
to identify novel viral genomes and
generate
reference sequences
scientists at the peter doherty
institute for infection and immunity
in melbourne australia we're one of the
first groups outside of china to
sequence the
tsar's coherent genome using our applied
biosystems genetic analyzers
with the sikh studio platform shown in
the middle
they were able to rapidly conduct
sequencing and generate a reference
sequence
which is now fueling global surveillance
research
next generation sequencing can also be
used for discovery and identification
of novel pathogens the two approaches
that are commonly used for
viral research include total rna
sequencing
shown on the right which employs rapid
de novo sequencing
of viral genomes including sarus kov2
as well as a targeted resequencing
approach
that is fueled by our flagship ion
amplicy technology
the ion ampliseq sars kobe 2 research
essay
surveys the complete sars kobe 2 genome
with greater than 99
coverage the assay allows you to access
all potential stereotypes and as i
mentioned this targeted resequencing
approach
allows you to access a wide variety of
biological samples
with the highest sensitivity
the assay is backed by a complete
informatics suite
for variant identification and
annotation
and consensus sequence assembly for all
of the viral genomes
present in your biological symbols
so let me switch gears now and tell you
how our genetic analysis
technologies enable epidemiological
surveillance research
so why is epidemiology important in
public health
well it allows us to understand how the
virus evolves over time
across different geographies and
populations
it informs us about disease severity
why are some people infected with the
virus
asymptomatic while others suffer from
severe respiratory distress
it provides novel insights about the
mode of transmission
how exactly did this virus
originally in baths make its way to the
human population
and it also provides us the ability to
perform surveillance
to see how quickly this virus
is evolving and spreading across the
population
so we can implement robust methods for
their control
as i mentioned previously the benefits
of next generation sequencing for
infectious disease research
include confirmation of virus detection
across a wide variety of samples with
extremely
high sensitivity as well as
epidemiological research where we open
up
applications such as viral evolution
studies
and surveillance research
so let me take a minute to highlight a
number of applications that have been
enabled
with our next generation sequencing
approach
the first is contact tracking and
tracing
at the children's hospital of los
angeles a subject of his mother
showed signs of covid19 simultaneously
with four other health care workers
obviously the immediate concern was
about
transmission of the disease between the
subject
and the front line health care workers
after the healthcare workers tested
positive by qpcr
for the virus the children's hospital of
los angeles made the decision to perform
next generation sequencing on
all of the samples including
those from the subject and his mother
comparative sequencing analysis across
the six
samples showed that the mother and the
son had nearly
identical strains of the virus that
originated
in utah with links to europe
while the other four healthcare workers
had strains
only distantly related to each other as
well as the family
these results confirmed that there was
no transmission between the subject his
family and the health care workers
this information really provided
children's hospital of los angeles
greater confidence in their
ability to provide a safe environment
for their subjects and their frontline
healthcare team members
another application that's been enabled
by next generation sequencing
is zoonotic transmission as i mentioned
before
the sars cov2 virus has thought to
originate in baths
so how did it transfer to the human
population
one theory is that intermediate hosts
facilitate this process using our next
generation sequencing technologies
scientists reported the identification
of sars cov2-related coronaviruses
and pangolins these animals whose
pictures shown on the left here were
seized in an
anti-smuggling operation in southern
china
the metagenomic sequencing analysis
identified that these
pangolin-associated coronaviruses
belong to two sublineages of
sars cov2 related coronaviruses
including one with a
receptor binding domain very closely
related to the sars covitu virus
the discovery of multiple lineages of
pangolin coronavirus and their
similarity to sars kov2
suggests that pangolins might be
intermediate hosts for this novel human
virus
and should be removed from wet markets
to prevent
zoonotic transmission
another emerging area of studying using
our ngs technology
is wastewater-based epidemiology
this approach has been proposed to
monitor the diffusion and trend of the
sars-kobe-2 crisis
so in italy raw and treated water
samples from
three wastewater treatment plants and
two river samples were characterized and
surveyed
for the presence of saskov2 virus
whole genome sequencing and phylogenetic
analyses
indicated that the isolated viruses
belong to the most prevalent strain in
europe
and had similarity to another strain
found in lombardy
this waste water sequencing application
may be able to act as an early warning
system for infectious disease
outbreaks in general and for the
immediate future
could help predict a second wave
of sars-cov2 infections
finally i'll highlight how our next
generation sequencing
targeted approach really allows us to
understand
viral evolution and inform vaccine
efficacy
two independent research teams in italy
used
the ion ampliseq sars cov2 research
panel
to identify a low number of variants in
samples obtained locally two months
after the virus was first sequenced in
china
the relatively low mutation rate of the
sars-kobe-2
virus is positive news for vaccine
research
as it indicates that the vaccine could
be
effective possibly over many many years
so as i've described how our next
generation sequencing systems
have opened up a wide variety of
applications for
infectious disease research let me
present to you
our complementary platforms on the left
is our ion gene studio s5
series this platform
really enables a wide variety of
applications
and provides the scalability and
throughput
for a number of different projects which
may involve
studies on immune response microbiome
and vaccine research and development
this platform is ideal for labs looking
for a cost-effective solution
for processing a large number of
infectious disease
research samples or those doing broader
viral research applications
on the right is our genetic genexis
integrated sequencer
which has really leveraged all of our
efforts
around highly automating the ngs
workflow
you can go from nucleic acid to report
in a single day with a hands-off
automated workflow
this platform is ideal for labs that are
new
to in-house ngs and want to leverage
the highly automated workflow not only
for sars co v2 research
but also for other clinical research
applications
in the future
our sars kobe 2 research solutions
are backed by a complete informatics
suite
which allows for analysis and
interpretation
our plugin package
allows you to identify and annotate
variants of interest again to inform
host response and disease severity
as well as allow for the ability to
build
consensus sequences with two different
plugins that use
different approaches one is reference
assistance assembly and the other is a
de novo
assembly approach
during this coronavirus pandemic
it's been incredibly difficult to keep
your lab and projects running
with the restricted travel and limited
access to your institutions
and that's why thermo fisher scientific
prides itself
in providing the utmost
service and support during these
critical times
with activities including desktop remote
support support remote monitoring
and diagnostic service and even
interactive
self-paced education modules
we provide the ability for customers to
continue
their critical research projects
especially
in these critical times while we're
facing a public
health crisis
so to conclude at thermal fissure
scientific
our mission is to enable customers to
make the world healthier
cleaner and safer the global covit 19
outbreak is a powerful reminder of that
mission
and our obligation as a solution
provider
to continue to support our customers
and leverage our capabilities to address
this rapidly
evolving public health crisis
to learn more about our genetic analysis
solutions for sars cov2 research
i invite you to visit our website
and i thank you today for your undivided
attention
thank you dr shah for that great
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of this presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
any questions that are submitted and not
answered today in the interest of time
will be addressed via email
dr shah we have a question here um the
question is
will you be able to share some more
information around the bio
safety feature using ngs for covid
testing
and an aerosol and decontamination
measures in this system
sure i'm happy to do that so typically
when
covid samples are retrieved
there are a couple of measures that are
required to make it
a into a state
where the samples can be processed
safely
so typically some of the
measures to inactivate the virus could
include some kind of heat treatment or
putting the sample in a special type of
medium
that allows the virus to be inactivated
and to be handled
safely going forward as it's used
in the uh sequencing workflow
um with our systems uh
the ion gene studio system as well as
the ion genexis system
there are various features within those
systems and their workflows that allow
for decontamination
[Music]
some of those include for example using
a
uv to decontaminate
between runs of samples
to ensure that you know there isn't
cross-contamination or any type of
sample mix-up
thank you so much for that um our second
question
um we have an audience member who would
like to know
what are the similarities that were
found in
the kovi 2 and kovi 19 with respect to
the 3d structure
is that something you're able to comment
on
um so let me
make sure i understand the question
covid19
refers to the condition or
the health
uh situation you know so you are
infected by the sars covita virus
and then you present yourself with
covid19
symptoms so i want to make sure that um
we're clear on the terminology sars kobe
2 refers to the viral
genome and its related sequences and
covid19
refers to the health condition
with respect to some of the
information that's been found there
are i think over 50 000
sequences that have been just deposited
into the public
databases including jisaid
and uh many of those uh
samples that have been sequenced show
some changes
uh in the sequence that um
may impact um the
uh the viral um
infectivity and i think um dr
uh trish will be talking about that more
in detail in his presentation
fantastic thank you so much um what is
your view
of ngf testing versus qpcr testing in
terms of
advantages and challenges
sure that's a great question and so
qpcr is normally used for detection
so what that test does is say that the
virus is present in a sample or not
what ngs does is provide more
information
it provides the complete sequence of the
virus and it gives us information
about how the virus is evolving
how the changes in the sequence in
specific
samples may contribute to disease
severity
and you know how
certain changes in the viral genome may
also impact the relative risk or the
infectivity of that virus and again
you're going to hear a lot more of those
details from dr
trish's presentation next
fantastic um there is a question here
from the audience and
um i'm sure they'd love to hear your
opinion
um are there any updates on the vaccine
or where we're at
with finding a vaccine for covert 19
uh i would say this that there are
um several efforts regarding
vaccine development that are ongoing uh
at present um obviously
uh vaccines need to go through
quite a bit of rigorous testing most
vaccines go
through some form of clinical trials and
so
all of those efforts are undergoing
currently
and um but usually vaccine development
and release of those vaccines
to the general public usually take you
know more than
a year sometimes two years depending on
what the vaccine is
or what condition it's being used for
and how quickly the virus or the
pathogen is mutating
so that we can get an idea of the
vaccine efficacy
thank you so much for that um i think
i'd like to take the opportunity to let
everyone know that we do have a talk
focusing on the applications of our
vaccine research
and solutions for that tomorrow and it's
the first talk again at the
beginning of this session once again i'd
like to remind everyone
if you have any questions please do put
them in the chat box
and we can get dr shah to answer them
for you
we have another question here um how
much time will it take
for the vaccine to be released in the
market i think it's a bit related to
your previous
answer would you like to elaborate any
further on that please
yeah like i said uh the best estimates
and
and again dr trish may be able to
comment more but
generally uh release of vaccines take
anywhere between one or two years
uh there are several uh
institutions or companies that are
working on development of vaccines
so i don't think i'm uh best equipped to
answer those questions
but there is a lot of
hope that a vaccine
will be able to stop the
spread of the pandemic and
people can access the vaccine more
broadly
thank you so much anjali again for your
presentation and thank you to the
audience for all your questions
our next speaker for this section is dr
timothy
dr trish is the co-director of the
children's hospital los angeles
uh children's hospital in los angeles uh
center for personalized medicine
he has previously served as chief of the
chla department of pathology and
laboratory medicine
for over 20 years at chla
he directs a cancer genomics biology and
nanotechnology laboratory research
program
for a complete biography on dr trish
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today dr trish will further expand and
share with us
the implications of viral sequencing
focusing on his experience at the
children's hospital in los angeles
please submit your questions in the q a
box and dr trish will address them at
the end of his presentation
please join me in welcoming dr timothy
trish
so it's a pleasure and i want to first
start by
acknowledging that i actually represent
a group of people
at children's hospital and our center
for personalized medicine
who've all been working together to
develop the tools to analyze
the viral sequence that
test positive by our upfront pcr test
children's hospital like many hospitals
has been developing
the tools for both detecting the virus
using the conventional pcr reaction as
well as serology assay to identify the
antibodies
but in the middle of that we feel an
important part of this is to take those
positive isolates
and sequence them to identify a number
of features and this first
i think illustrates a couple of obvious
points from a pre-print that was posted
recently
and by our archive expressing concerns i
think
we all share which is that the genomic
regions multiple genomic regions and
this virus are prone to a high rate of
mutation
and the consequences of that are
currently unknown
one could very reasonably worry about
things like inner logic escape of the
virus as well
as development of resistance to
antiviral drugs as well as the effect on
molecular diagnostics and even future
vaccine development
so for that reason we have been
increasingly interested
in developing uh if you will a portfolio
or understanding of the
character of the sequence of the virus
as well of course as
the uh shall we say the spread of the
virus and the public health implications
so with that let me see if i can
click there we go by way of introduction
before we get into the detail i just
want to remind everybody
a few features about this virus that i
think are a particular concern
i think by this time hopefully everybody
is aware that the portal of entry is the
h2 receptor
which is expressed on multiple tissues
and nasopharynx as well as in the lungs
and that has a lot to do with the
pathogenicity it also represents a
potential therapeutic target
and as well as for vaccine development
and
i think therefore changes in the
sequence of the spike protein
among others is of course a particular
interest because that's the first step
in the process of infection as
illustrated in this cartoon
i think the the next to be aware of is
that
the virus as we all know is obviously
closely related to a number of bad virus
isolates as illustrated in this slide
and thus
uh it's likely that the obviously
evolved from it and even though there's
a tremendous amount of sequence uh
identity between the bad virus and this
sars virus
nonetheless as illustrated also in this
phylogenetic tree
nonetheless it is a distinct virus quite
distinct from
a predecessor the sars co-v virus or any
bat virus
and there's some very important
implications of this and they're all
based on the sequence of this particular
isolate
to return to the point that i made in a
moment ago though i wanted to point out
that there's a lot of discussion about
the mutation rate in this virus
and there are numerous publications now
that document that there are widespread
mutations
throughout the entire viral genome which
as you see displayed here
has about 30 kb in length um and has
roughly 10 uh coding genes the largest
one the orf 1ab
is used twice the complicated encoding
mechanism
and the second one indicated here under
s is the spike protein that i alluded to
a moment ago
and one might reasonably ask what is the
effect of mutations here
and how frequent are they and that's one
of the things that we've focused a great
deal of attention on
um but before going into the details i
also want to point out that mutations
per se
may or may not mean anything and a
relatively nice study
done from the diamond princess cruise
ship comparing mutations
in that group to others as seen in the
left side here
you'll notice that there are three
categories the so-called synonymous
non-synonymous and intergenic region
mutations important to note is that
synonymously
sequence variants of course do not
result in an amino acid coding sequence
change
and therefore are not likely to affect
the protein
mis endogenic regions likewise would
have little effect
but the non-synonymous mutations by
definition will result in a protein
coding change
and thus the mutations which as you know
here are the most frequent group
and if you further categorize them as
seen in the right-hand panel
specifically mapped
the viral human a viral genome you'll
notice that
not surprisingly the second most common
site of mutations across the viral
genome
is in fact the spike protein the one
that we referred to a moment ago
and this may have very important
potentials and potential implications in
term of public health
um the next slide focuses a little bit
more attention
um on the spike protein itself um
which is to give you some idea of the
organization
of the spike protein you see here that
there's an n-terminal domain and a green
receptor binding domain
a fragment that is cleaved between the
s1 and s2 fragment
and the carboxy terminal n the important
point is
that this particular protein
is the site of entry as a trimeric
protein it obviously enables the virus
to bind to the h2 receptor and then with
cleavage at the s1 s2 site
exposed the s1 fragment which is in fact
the part
of the spiked protein responsible for
fusion with the cell membrane and
insertion of the viral contents
as shown in that earlier cartoon the
consequence of course
that is viral infection and replication
so a great deal of the biology of this
virus is
encompassed in analysis of the spike
protein
and thus the interest in following
mutations in the spike protein in
particular um
there have been several papers as
summarized here documenting that many of
the mutations in fact do occur in the
spike protein
in both the internal domain as seen here
as well as in the receptor binding
domain
and then a couple other additional sites
and in addition i'll point out that
one of the unique features of this virus
compared to its predecessors in the
coronavirus family
is the insertion of about four amino
acids
exactly at the s1 s2 cleavage site
this creates a so-called fern cleavage
site which is typically historically
associated with increased
pathogenicity so clearly this is not a
good development of
the viewpoint of the biologic behavior
of the disease
the other thing that's important to note
is the receptor binding domain is also
unique
this slide illustrates uh in the lower
detail in the left the green
mapped area is in fact the carboxy
terminal receptor binding area
and in more detail on the right you'll
see in green
and gray two versions of that domain
the green version is in fact the current
encobate if you will as whereas the gray
is in fact the original sars and it's
obvious that the
three-dimensional structure of the
receptor binding domain
this virus is very very different and
that again of course
is dictated by the viral sequence one
can readily imagine
that even though there's near identity
between the predecessor sars
covid and this one in fact the
antibodies against the original one do
not appear to cross-react it so it comes
down to
very small sequence variations
completely determining things like your
antibody response
and potentially immunity to the virus so
for all of these reasons
we've focused a great deal of tension in
taking the
viral isolates that we've identified
from a children's hospital
and subjecting them to sequencing
as angelica's actually um described in
great detail before
in the first part of this presentation
so i won't go into the details
instead i will focus on some of the data
that we've generated
and the potential clinical and public
health implications
first thing to note is that this is an
example of
a run of eight samples which includes a
positive synthetic control at the top
and the fortuity happens the second one
appears to be a highly rna degraded
sample
but the next four are all negatives and
you can tell that because
there is the positive controls the human
control spiked in here
as well as a positive process control
here but there is effectively no
or very few uh reads and notice the
first one does appear to have
a few reads here whereas others appear
to completely negative
and so this is important because these
are pcr negative samples
um the last three are known positives
and you see
a very large number of reads as
predicted in the 225 base
range which is the size of the amplicon
primers
and of course the more sample you have
the more positive
reads are over the sample as opposed to
the normal controls
and thus high to lower tighter it's
important to be aware of tighter in fact
what we've found is
it's very useful to know the ct values
of the original pcr reaction
when deciding how to load the chips
because as seen in the left side of this
panel
you'll notice that there is a relatively
low loading
as seen in this sort of blue-green sort
of
density of the chip so that this was
because there were so many negative
samples from that previous
uh group uh there was the chip was under
loaded and therefore the number reads
were low
another important thing that we've
discovered is that
development of libraries manually um is
quite uh important because they the more
experienced
the investigator the more reliable
the the libraries that result from the
two library pools
i mean the primer pools when one doesn't
take great care
and doing this manually you can end up
with unbalanced primer poles which gives
you unbalanced reads of course which is
unhelpful
in contrast we've found that with the
chef or extremely
experienced operators we're able to get
nicely balanced primer pools
which gives us uniformity of reeds
across the entire viral genome
and for reasons that i won't go into now
it's quite important
particularly a laboratory environment in
which we operate
to try to develop the highest degrees of
uniformity in these library preparations
despite some of the issues i noted a
moment ago this slide illustrates
a negative control on the left ear and a
positive
uh excuse me a negative sample on the
left and a positive on the right
you'll notice that the expected reads
are uniform and well represented
they all pass qc the overall size is
read base read length as indicated here
is exactly what we would expect the
negative ones there is essentially
nothing to be seen except the human
positive
controls seen on the right these are
these assays are done for qc reasons on
all of the samples
so uh the data of course from all these
sequencing guns ultimately must be put
into a database and analyzed
at chla our bioinformatics center uh
which is headed by dr xiaohu guy has
created
this platform for analyzing namples and
as it turns out fortuitously it went
live in the
amazon web service cloud just earlier
today
and the address is as you see indicated
here these are the tools that he and his
group have developed for analyzing the
samples
i want to show you an example of
particular relevance
in a clinical setting as we have in our
hospital
what you see here are six samples
isolated from
children's hospital samples two of whom
were from
a child and a parent and the other four
from healthcare workers
are in the same facility in the same
area
as the parent and child note that you
see here what appears to be five samples
there are five distinct clusters in this
phylogenetic tree
or if you say samples that cluster as
you see here
from one through four and then five and
six
and what is interesting is if you look
at the last two samples
here indicated they are both if you will
nearly identical in the phylogenetic
tree and that in fact represents
the parent and the child and so this was
important because the other four showed
no
relationship to these two and the
clinical situation that arose was
whether or not in fact individuals being
admitted to the hospital might be in
fact the
staff health care staff or whether
individuals could have been infected
from
health care staff the very rewarding and
encouraging result of this as you can
see
is that clearly both uh the
parent and child brought the infection
in from a separate source
from the health care workers which
themselves obviously acquired it from
community spread from different sources
because each viral isolate was different
from the other
among the healthcare workers and only
the parent and child
showed identical samples this sort of
analysis is incredibly important in
terms
in terms of understanding infectious
disease spread not just in a hospital
but in a community setting as well
and thus as more and more these analyses
take place it will allow us to
understand
how this virus spreads and among which
populations
and eventually do contact tracing and
identify index cases
last thing i'd like to mention in
passing is the issue
of the mutation that we discussed so
much and the implications
this is the table of data from multiple
viral isolates
looking at allele frequency from 75
percent on the right down to one percent
on the left
and you'll notice that the number of
apparent mutations
increases dramatically as you go to low
read
depth excuse me allele frequency
remember that we're looking at five to
eight thousand reads
per base uh as we currently perform the
analysis
and the important thing is that things
like 25 percent and above are readily
identified
for example in the light blue sample as
you see
here there are no reliable mutations
identified
at 25 and higher and this is pretty much
identical across the board
eight eight nine eight five ten as you
see
so at twenty five percent above uh you
get uniformity of data suggesting that
that is
quote the clone on the other hand uh
if you look at lower level frequency ten
percent and below
you start seeing more and more apparent
mutations
and the focus of interest right now of
course is determining which of these are
real
and confirming these data because these
potentially represent the emergence of
new
mutant clones within a single host and
the implications for that of course
are completely unknown but it
undoubtedly relates to the emergence of
multiple claims of this virus over time
so and the final point is understanding
where these all come from and who they
relate to it's useful to have a tool
such as this viral genome tracker
tool that has been developed whereby any
given sequence
of a virus can be compared to any other
around the world
there's over 13 000 currently deployed
and this of course then allows you to
identify potentially the origins of the
isolate you're working with compared
ultimately
to the overall as i say over 13 000
already
posted so i'd like to close by making a
few points that i hope
were apparent but if not let me repeat
them the first point is
that this virus obviously derived from a
bad coronavirus is similar to a
predecessor
cyrus kovee has very distinct genomic
features and those are
only really identified when you do viral
sequencing
and they probably relate to important
biologic parameters like the affinity
for the h2 receptor which incidentally
is 20 fold greater in this version of
the cyrus virus as opposed to the
original one
another point i think it's worth going
and i think we've documented that
is it undergoes rapid mutation within a
host and between
individuals as it spreads in the
community thus allowing one to document
viral spread over time at a public
health level
as well as identifying isis within a
hospital setting and knowing you know
who is at risk and who's not and who is
potentially impacting others
or not this of course allows us to
identify
these index cases and community spread
and ultimately to do contact tracing
um what i think is also interesting why
we're spending so much time sequencing
these viruses
we've been trying to understand what are
the overall medical or clinical
implications of these variants in the
virus ultimately we think
the coast and the virus obviously have a
complex biologic relationship
and that almost certainly changes as the
viral secret changes as well
we'll ultimately be very interested in
comparing the term excuse me variants of
the virus
with the clinical disease as we progress
with these studies and so this of course
at a very larger level as i indicated at
the outset also i think has potentially
very very significant implications for
the future
of viral diagnostic testing as well as
development of therapeutic interventions
because
as a very highly rapidly mutating
rna virus i.e it is after all just a
version of the common cold virus
it's not surprising that these efforts
that
for example develop molecular
diagnostics based on a specific sequence
or vaccines or other antivirals that are
focused on a certain sequence themselves
may be less effective in the future if
in fact this continues to
evolve as we are seeing here and with
that i'd like to
close and thank our group particularly
in the molecular genomics core and
bioinformatics team
within the center for personalized
medicine the children's hospital
uh dr ostrow in particular has been
processing all these samples with her
team
uh and dr jabo guy and his team have
been analyzing all the data
are responsible for all of the content
that you've seen here
and with that i'd like to close and
thank you very much
hello
hello oh my goodness
dude unmuted okay
i am not muted okay hello
[Music]
thank you so much dr trish for that
presentation
we'll now move into the live q a portion
of this presentation
as i can see a lot of questions coming
in through our chat box
um the first question i was going to ask
you which therapeutic drugs are showing
most response in treating infected
patients
and do you think the whole promise
regarding treatment
that's a a very important question and
it's one that's rapidly evolving
i think it's good to go back to basics
remember that the virus
itself does relatively limited damage it
obviously causes the cells in which it
replicates to die
but the consequences of that are what
really causes the disease that we call
covet 19.
as a result the patient's immune
response to the virus
pretty much determines the severity of
the disease and the character of the
disease
so many of the currently effective
interventions
are focusing on modulating or dampening
the patient's immune response and it
seems that number one
on that list at the moment is a very
cheap and readily available drug
dexamethasone which obviously like all
steroids
blunts the immune response and
diminishes the severity
of most of the symptoms including sars
as well as other symptoms
of the disease remdissevere is a popular
drug
not inexpensive because it directly
interferes with viral replication
but from what i've seen so far it has
actually perhaps
less uniform efficacy than dexamethasone
also there are a number of other drugs
that are coming into use
most of which are modulating one or
another aspects of the immune response
many of the cytokine inhibitors are
becoming popular because
much of the damage appears to be related
to interleukins for example
and finally because a lot of the immune
response is related to macrophages
direct inhibitors of macrophages
themselves
these so-called brutin kinase inhibitors
appear to be effective in diminishing
the
extent of the macrophage response which
is the cell that ultimately presents
the viral antigen to cease t cells and b
cells
and leads to the rapid and rather fierce
immune response that we see as so-called
cova-19 and
sars and some of the other symptoms
we've seen so i think
the the good news is that multiple drugs
are showing
some degree of efficacy but of course
what everyone's interested in is they
call
drug that allows direct treatment and
prevention of the symptoms of the
disease has not yet been identified
and personally i believe that the
cocktail of drugs that are being
increasingly
finely tuned are the more important
approach to treating the disease today
thank you so much tim we have another
question can you elaborate a little more
on the qc incorporated into your panel
um is the spike in to verify the ngs
workflow or does it include your reverse
transcriptase and extraction
part of the workflow as well sure the
the spiken as currently uh used is
actually
a set of primers to detect i believe
it's five human genes
and those uh the reason for that of
course is that they represent positive
controls
because when you do any sort of sampling
whether it's a nasopharyngeal swab
a nasal swab or even an oral buccal swab
or
saliva even there will be contained
within that
human genes of course the rna from them
so that in the process of the reverse
transcription
and creation of the cdna and then the
amplification of the cdna
you will have the opportunity to have a
positive control
of human genes and if they're not there
then you know that you have a complete
analytic failure and you can't in
believe any of the result
if those positive controls the human
genes
appear then you know that the viral gene
results are reliable
and you can count on them and interpret
them appropriately
the one thing i will note and we're
working closely with thermo fisher on
this right now
is that as we encounter patient samples
with very very low viral titer
too many of the reeds are being
accounted for by the
human normal gene control and we are
working on tools with thermo to dampen
the number of such reads so that we get
more reads
from the very very few viral reads
present in the sample
the value of that is that we believe we
will be able to lower
the lower limit of detection of viral
sequence
to extremely low levels once we do that
and that's becoming important because
many of the patients after
peaking show a prolonged tale of viral
shedding
and one of the things we would like to
know is whether or not such patients of
course
represent an infectious threat to their
community and those around them or not
and we don't know the answer to that yet
one possible interpretation is in fact a
lot of that material
is actually just a residual viral
replication that is being interrupted
and effectively destroyed by the
patient's immune response and then what
we're detecting
is viral fragments of fragmented rna
from the virus
which does not have infectious
capability so we are focusing more
attention
on these low viral tighter smaller rna
fragments
and trying to get more reads from them
so we can answer that question but at
the moment we don't know the answer to
the question
thank you so much we have another
question here
how many mutant strains of the virus
have been identified till now
is each mutant strain more pathogenic
than the one before
and are there any strains which have
reduced pathogenicity
from which they have been mutated
that's a very difficult question and not
to be
facetious one of the things that i'm
very concerned about
is that in every patient isolate we have
multiple multiple viral strains so
one of the things that's become very
obvious is that
there are innumerable viral strains
innumerable
on the other hand remember i mentioned
allele frequency
if we focus on 25 or greater allele
frequency
the actual number of different distinct
viral clades or
variants if you will is much lower
what is most important though is that we
are seeing the emergence of
certain variants the so-called d614g
being a classic example and the only
reason that's important is it
seems as though that particular strain
takes over in any given population
it was first reported in europe as the
most common variant
then it showed up on the east coast as
the most common variant
and now it has shown up on the west
coast as the most common variant
but the important thing is that
it seems to be superimposed on unique
sequences that we find
on the west coast the same thing
happened on the east coast
the same thing happened in europe so it
would appear to be
a sort of a darwinian process whereby
the d614 and g
variant appears on top of whatever your
local
variety of viruses may be because it
appears to have a replication advantage
as of today however we don't have any
evidence that there's any increase in
pathogenicity
but it does seem to be a more successful
variant
because it tends to become the dominant
isolate in any given population over
time
fortunately as i said we don't see any
evidence that
it causes any more severe disease but it
does obviously mean
that the virus may well be more
efficient and therefore potentially more
infectious
and certainly potentially more abundant
in patients who are shedding the virus
which of course is the main concern from
a public health viewpoint
so a simple way of answering the
question is i think
we any given patient can give rise to
any number
of variants and what's more important is
the darwinian process of which
variants are going to prove to be more
successful over time
and that's something we don't know yet
because it's still very much a process
in evolution
and the big fear of course as i've
mentioned earlier in this
presentation is that we certainly hope
that we don't see emergence of strains
that are markedly more pathogenic or
more
grossly successful at provoking covid19
i.e the disease
or clinical symptoms that we see with
infection and
so far that appears to be the case we
haven't seen emergence of a distinct
variant
that causes a distinctive group of
symptoms but i think we all know now
we are just beginning to understand the
full spectrum of disease
that is seen in these patients and i
would remind you that
this is something i.e the virus
sequence and the type of disease that's
caused
and associated with it is something you
can only do with next-gen sequencing
because of course
pcr testing will not give you any of
this information
so we are still sequencing all of our
positive cases
in an effort to understand issues like
the cause the effect of variation
in viral sequence with the character of
the clinical disease
but so far there is no distinct
correlation that we've identified
between any given viral sequence and the
character of the disease that it causes
fantastic thank you so much for that uh
insight dr truth
we do have a fair few questions that are
still coming but i think in the interest
of time
we might have to
i lost you there
but with that i'd like to say sorry oh i
your voice dropped out there for a
moment i'm sorry i didn't hear what you
said
i was just saying we do have a lot more
questions uh in the chat box but in the
interest of time
we might have to get them answered via
email
um and we will reach out to dr trish
with those questions
uh with that i'd like to conclude this
starscore v2 research application
session
we will now take a 15-minute break
before we start the next session
so grab a coffee walk around the event
and check out the various application
tracks that may be of your interest
during the break time please visit our
boots and learn about some very exciting
promotions
that are available to the audience and
interact with our former professional
representatives
who are available at the booths to
answer your questions
please do not forget to check the
leaderboard on the top right side of the
screen
to see what activities are available
including a scavenger hunt
and look out for our special icons in
the environment to win prizes
there will be a pop-up survey appearing
in a minute so please do help us by
completing the survey
thank you again and we'll see you back
in the auditorium in 15 minutes
thank you bye-bye thanks trish thank you